nice shoes i remember that girl
i have two different feet why should i
wear two different shoes
still works
[Applause]
newly single professional photographer
used to be fun i'm still fun here comes
the dance
can't stop won't stop
okay i'll stop raising three kids on my
own
i'm barely keeping it together it's time
for me to focus on myself and my
needs check him out i am not ready to
date again your father and i just broke
up
a fireman holy mackinawy
there's a little girl that needs a place
to stay while cherry finds her at home
because it goes clear
you must be izzy but we all have to
agree no absolutely not
okay here's the thing we're doing it
morning babe wait what just happened
you're not supposed to be here
we're divorced and don't call me babe
you called me babe you still have a
thing for him
[Music]
i want to focus on this family i'm
making pancakes
making pancakes
[Music]
your mom and i are still trying to
figure things out but we're still a
family
we just look a little different hungry i
think i'll just watch you explode
[Applause]
[Music]
there's something i have been missing my
punky power
pokey brewster is back
is that better
you